good job of the bell sweat down swell
it's a beautiful day gonna burn my truck
I'm going
good time
I'm along that
fallout 4 has been out for a couple of
weeks now and we've already spent most
of our non-working hours traipsing
around Boston it's safe to say they were
pretty in love with the game but even
the things you love have flaws what
we've done this week is picked out a few
things that we'd love to see in upcoming
patches mods and DLC of course we won't
get our entire Christmas list ticked off
but that's okay too and before you jump
into the comments the fact that we think
a few things could be better really
doesn't mean we hate the game really as
always make sure to tweet all your
fallout thoughts feelings and fan
creations at us using the hashtag GS
fallouts and you could see your very
name on the show so here are 10
suggestions for what we'd like to see in
fallout 4 let us know yours in the
comments if you've played fallout 4 any
significant period of time you'll be
familiar with the game's companions and
considering that only one of those
companions is a dog they sure do get
lost a lot we've started to consider
putting up missing posters around Boston
because we can never remember where we
told them to go there are about a
million bases around the wasteland all
of which are tiny and populated by idiot
AI so we'd really rather not check every
single one for our errant friends just
give us a handy companion finder please
the discovery that you can equip dogmeat
with armor and goggles was something
that ramped up our enjoyment of Fallout
4 by roughly two hundred percent
dressing up your setlist is one thing
but dressing up a dog is a whole
different kind of beauty pageant but why
can't you have matching outfits in fact
why can't you give dog me an entire set
of power armor he deserves it he's such
a good boy you can stuff your guns full
of adjectives until the Brahmin come
home but your melee upgrades are
basically limited to fire and barbed
wire which are both valid options sure
but what if we want to get a little more
creative with our baseball bat beatings
give us more variety with our Mellie and
perhaps we'd be enticed to put down the
minigun and pick up the sword it's still
possible to spend hours in the character
create a menu but having tried to create
a few celebrities we've realized that
it's actually not that customizable sure
you can tug on the jowls and tuck in the
neck and even add spots more spots and a
crazy amount of spots seriously why
there's so many zip options there's
you can't do we'd love to see a few more
character customization options bigger
but smaller eyes better hairstyles and
everything in between my companion keeps
telling me he loves me which is great
I've even got him wearing my spare
wedding ring and that doesn't make me a
monster but I want something more from
our relationship I know it's super hard
to animate but with a little
smoochy-smooch go amiss everything is
super depressing after all also it would
be nice to have the option to give you a
companion things to carry without them
thinking it's permission to use them fat
man's and grenades in particular
explosions are nice but only when we're
expecting them no one's really talking
about Mad Max anymore which is a shame
because it had a gorgeous photo mode you
could turn Mad Max upside down in the
middle of an explosion zooming in on his
pain face in black and white all you
wanted to imagine if we had the option
in fallout 4 selfies of the deathclaw
why not endless photos of dog meets
happy little face stick him in the album
it's little more than a glorified
screenshot mode but our lives and social
media feeds would never be the same
settlements are great they really are
but they're fiddly as hell we wouldn't
be saying this if we didn't want to
spend more time with them so really we
mean well but so far we've suffered from
setlist stuck on roofs difficulty
telling settlers apart ever knowing what
task settlers are assigned to and
settlers standing in doorways all the
freaking time just please we know it
doesn't really fit into the law but
please turn all the settlers into
mindless drones that we can control
rename and assign it will like bees just
replace all of the NPC's with bees waste
lands a big place and frankly our feet
are getting tired Skyrim has horses and
whilst we have vertibird they're not
exactly very practical who doesn't want
to jump on the back of a yaoguai a rad
scorpion or sit inside a super mutant
behemoth basket like the wastelands
answer to bran and Hodor no one that's
who we didn't realize how much we missed
being evil until we weren't explicitly
told about it anymore we can wander
through fall out for being a colossal
dick to everyone if we want and the
various NPCs and companions get a bit
huffy about it but we can't wander into
a completely new town and be instantly
reviled by all the people living there
who heard about that one time we show
an innocent father of three in the face
what's better than one shotgun two
shotguns obviously saying goes for
pistols swords baseball bats and power
fists after all we do have two fists in
real life we might as well use them sure
the combat is enjoyable and it's nice to
sever heads in a multitude of different
ways but it feels better when you do it
with both hands we might even feel more
like James Bond that way so that was our
list of 10 things that we would like to
see added to fallout 4 in the future
some might be a little bit
over-ambitious but we can always keep
our fingers crossed now to end the
episode as usual we're going to take a
look at some of the creations from
inside the community the first one comes
from sean bailey 0 on twitter and he has
made an adorable little market town
inside the slog if you haven't found the
slog yet it's a settlement inhabited
mostly by ghouls but just because the
inhabitants are the best-looking doesn't
mean you can't bake a beautiful
settlement so he's made it in time
market town I'm assuming this is done
using the updated settlement budget mod
because there is a lot to it all the
market stalls are in nice little shops
he has covered the swimming pool up
which means none of the ghouls can take
a refreshing dip he's got a night
lassila office on the top floor as well
so we can overlook his settlement
complete with power armor stationed desk
that you can watch no TV on unless you
really want to watch this please stand
by a great example of what you can do
with the settlement tools it is a pity
that you need to download mods to
actually build something giant and
detailed like that but hopefully in the
future there'll be more options for
Selma building but thank you for that
Sean awesome submission the next one is
a little bit maybe intense um as you can
see this death claw has torn apart this
poor individual and my favorite part of
this picture is that dog meat looks
absolutely terrified that and the sole
survivor is probably a little bit too
close to the deathclaw to use that
grenade he's clutching so if I had to
hazard a guess at sole survivor and and
dog me as well as that Raider are soon
going to be death
and finally a user on deviantart by the
name of prank 69 has taken all the
magazine covers and advertisements from
fallout 4 so you've got such gems as
Tesla magazine rocket science for
toddlers I wouldn't trust any child in
rocket science tales of a junkie town
jerky vendor why I sold my mother
Massachusetts Medical Journal surgical
journal even a cryo technology heaven or
tomb well tuned for some people live in
love I married a robot that sounds like
a futuristic Jerry Springer Show at the
moon communist doomsday device I think
about that every day grog nag the
Barbarian what sorcery is this again a
question I frequently asked myself and I
think the future inspiration for my new
tattoo anchorage obviously being the
Battle of Anchorage from fallout 3 and
I'm not sure it looked quite like that
but props to any future tattooist for
the inspiration there so like we said
the begin the episode if you have any
fallout art or if you want to share a
settlement with us make sure you tweet
it at us using the hashtag GS Fallout
and we will feature on the show next
week until then thank you so much for
watching remember to like and subscribe
to the fallout 4 show and until the next
episode stay safe are there ways now
wake up java the bell sweat down feet
swell
but he got into
don't go